foreign
over the years people have come up with
some truly awful apologies
from classic non-apologies to evasive
excuses and flimsy corporate promises
it's all too easy to give a bad apology
but researchers have found that good
apologies generally share certain
elements and thoughtfully considering
these factors can help you make amends
in a wide variety of situations
since public apologies have their own
unique complications we're going to
focus on some person-to-person examples
so picture this your new office has free
ice cream sandwiches in the communal
fridge or at least that's what you
thought but on Friday when you're
helping your co-worker Terence set up
another colleague's birthday party he
finds that half the ice cream he bought
for the celebration is gone while this
is obviously an embarrassing accident
coming forward and apologizing is still
the right thing to do
understanding and accepting
responsibility for your actions is what
some researchers call the centerpiece of
an apology
but it's okay if this feels difficult
and vulnerable it's supposed to be the
costly nature of apologies is part of
what makes them meaningful so while you
might be tempted to defend your actions
as accidental it's important to remember
that a good apology isn't about making
you feel better it's about seeking to
understand the perspective of the
wronged party and repair the damage to
your relationship this means that while
clarifying your intentions
non-defensively can be helpful your
mistake being an accident shouldn't
absolve you from offering a sincere
apology
but what if your mistake wasn't an
accident
consider this you promised your friend
Marie that you'll attend her
championship football match but another
friend just called to offer you an extra
ticket for your favorite musician's
farewell tour you know this is a once in
a lifetime chance and you can't pass it
up plus you figure Marie wouldn't mind
if you missed the game she always has
plenty of fans supporting her but the
next day Marie tells you she was really
hurt when she didn't see you in the
crowd you feel terrible for upsetting
her and genuinely want to apologize but
while you regret hurting Marie you're
not actually sure if you made the wrong
choice so how can you reach beyond that
terrible non-apology I'm sorry you feel
this way
in situations like this it can be easy
to focus on rationalizing your actions
when you should be working to understand
the other person's perspective
consider asking Marie how you made them
feel to better understand your offense
in this case Marie might explain that
she was disappointed you broke your
promise and she was really counting on
your support
this kind of clarity can help you
recognize your wrongdoing and honestly
accept how your actions caused harm
then you can frame your apology around
addressing her concerns perhaps by
admitting that it was wrong of you to
break your promise and you're sorry you
weren't there for her
clearly acknowledging wrongdoing
indicates that you know exactly how you
messed up and it can give Marie faith
that you'll behave differently moving
forward but it's always helpful to
indicate exactly how you'll change and
what you'll do to repair the damage
caused by your offense researchers call
this the offer of repair and it's often
rated as one of the most critical parts
of an apology
in some cases these gestures are
straightforward like offering to replace
the ice cream you ate however with less
tangible transgressions this might need
to be more symbolic like expressing your
love and respect for someone you wrong
one common offer of repair is a verbal
commitment not to make the same mistake
again but promising to do better only
works if you actually do better
taking the victim's perspective
accepting responsibility and making
concrete offers of repair are just a few
of the elements of a good apology but
remember apologies aren't about getting
forgiveness and moving on they're about
expressing remorse and accepting
accountability
and the best apologies are just the
first step on the road to reconciliation
taking the time to apologize properly
can sometimes require us to regulate our
emotions first but how do you actually
do that find out with this video or get
more actionable science-based advice on
how to build character at ed.ted.com
forward slash build character